Okay, good morning everyone. This is
Mike from orderflows and I'm happy to
kick off today's investor inspiration uh
All right, hey everyone. It's Mike
Kobaltos from orderflows.com and I'm
happy to kick off today's investor
inspiration
top traders tips webinar event and today
I'll be talking about order flow
specifically finding high winning
percentage trades with order flow and my
goal for you today is to discuss the new
developments in order flow analysis and
explain why they are important.
Two is I'm going to show you how to find
high winning percentage trades with
order flow analysis and I'm going to
talk about why you should stop waiting
for confirmation and just start trading.
Now, you know, they gave me a nice lead
up into this but I just want to talk
about you know who I am, where I come
from so you can understand better that
what I talk about comes from real world
real world experience. So,
for the past three years I've founded
and run orderflows.com
and prior to that I spent eight years as
VP of futures trading at JP Morgan. You
know, this was a job where I sat on the
trading desk trading all day long from
5:00 in the morning till close to 5:00
at night and you know, it wasn't a
job where I just sit back and I look at
spreadsheets and would stick my head out
of an office and say, "Hey, you know
what? You're you're exceeding your
risk." or anything like that. No, this
was a trading job. Prior to that I spent
four years with Cargill as a trading
desk manager where I traded literally
every known futures contract that was
available from you know, the Biffex, the
Baltic Freight Shipping Index to you
know, South African white maize to you
know, rapeseed and canola oil, palm oil,
Tokom rubber, everything that's traded
exchange traded I traded there and prior
to that I spent three years at
Commerzbank. I was a licensed Eurex
trader where I traded bonds, bobbles,
schats, um
DAX, Euro stocks
and I traded them also against the US
counterparts. You know, the And bond is
a 10-year contract, I traded it against
US 10s. And you know, I traded
US stocks against S&Ps. So,
you know, I I I've really been
experienced exposed to a lot of
different commodities and futures
contracts, you know, indices,
currencies, everything that you could
imagine, you know, 2 years I spent at
EDF Man as a global macro trader. I
started on the CME floor with Dean
Witter as a runner, you know, the very
bottom of the industry that you can get
started in in those days. You know,
unfortunately, now there's no trading
floor. So, you know, it's hard to get
started in the trading industry unless
you
you know, go to a top school and have a
degree in um mathematical
um analysis or, you know, computer
programming. It's very difficult to get
hired.
But, you know, once I started seeing
that trading was start was going
electronic back in the early '90s, I
left the trading floor to work upstairs
on their their Globex desk at that time.
You know, we had Globex A, which is the
CBOT, we had NYMEX access. And then
that's where I became um exposed to all
the different futures contracts that
traded around the world. You know, when
you're on the trading floor, all you
deal with is is one contract. You know,
if you're in the Eurodollar pit, that's
all you traded, you know, it was
Eurodollars. You know, I had a friend
that ran the bond desk for Aubrey
Lanston and
yeah, he had no concept, you know,
everyone thought he was the the expert
because he followed bonds, 10 years and
5 years.
You know, they thought, "Wow, you can
follow so many contracts, you're an
expert." And then when he saw what we do
upstairs on the trading desk, you know,
we deal with all the US contracts, all
the European contracts, all the Asian
contracts, you know, you got 10 years in
in the UK, which are the gilts. In those
days, you had the French notional bonds,
which is 10-year contract, obviously the
Bunds. Um
and then in Japan, you know, you had the
JGBs, a 10-year contract. You know, his
mind was blown away, you know, like I
said, you know, he thought everyone was
kept telling him, "Oh, you're an
expert." because you know, he understood
just bonds, US bonds, 5 years and and
and 10 years. But, you know, he had no
idea that there was this whole other
world going on out there and you know,
sometimes traders get so caught up in
one market that they failed to
realize what else is out there. So, you
know, the reason I I say this, you know,
the reason I talk about my background is
just so you can understand that you
know, what I'm about to talk about comes
from real-world trading experience, you
know, and it's not me sitting in a dorm
room
trading on a, you know, a
a small sim account, you know, or a a
small live trading account with 100
bucks in it, you know, trading micro mic
nano lots or something in in FX. No, you
know, I traded big positions. I've
traded positions as well into the
thousands of contracts at a time. So,
you know, that's my background and
hopefully
um you know, you can take away something
from this presentation. And you know,
what I'm presenting here is what I've
developed for myself and built my
trading career on. And I hope you can
find things you can use or things you
can modify and adapt for your own
trading. You know, I'm not saying you
have to follow what I say just because I
say it. No, you have to evaluate
everything you come across whether it's
from me or elsewhere and decide if it's
going to help you. If not, reject it,
you know,
trading is a journey, I think, and
you know, where you are now
versus where you were a year ago, 5
years ago, if you've been trading that
long,
you know, it's probably vastly
different, you know, I I know I
progressed as a trader. Um you know, at
one time I thought
Japanese candlesticks were were it, you
know, I thought this was it, you know,
this is what's going to make me a
millionaire, you know, in the next year
just by looking for a certain
candlestick patterns. No, it's not it's
not like that. Um you know, I had to go
on a journey find what works for me,
what didn't work, take different pieces
of analysis, you know, like I I I was
very fortunate that I had exposure to a
lot of great traders
back in those days. And nowadays, you
know, it's very difficult to get
exposure or get contact with a lot of
people that have been trading
professionally, you know, as a living,
you know, doing that's what they did.
And, you know, for me, trading that's
how
you know, I I support myself. That's how
I pay for my house, pay for my car, you
know, pay for everything, you know, my
kids, insurance, school, everything is
is through trading. And
like I said, you know, trading is a
journey and you and you
it it's not something that you can just
pick up, you know, instantly, you know,
unless you're like Rain Man or
something, but even that, you know, not
everybody is going to be successful in
trading. Not everybody has what it takes
to be a successful trader.
And that's why I like doing these
webinars with Investor Inspiration is
because it exposes you to many different
types of market analysis. And, you know,
like I said, you know, if you don't
learn something from me, hopefully you
can learn something from someone else
here. So, let me be clear, you know, you
have to make decisions, whether it's in
life
or trading. You know, that's what
trading is about, it's about making
decisions. But when you understand order
flow, you're going to understand the
market and the decisions
that you're going to make will become
very clear. And that's important because
think about it in in everyday terms,
right? When you go to cross the street,
excuse me. I got a sore throat here.
Like I said, I cough.
You know, when when you look up at the
traffic light, you don't have to think,
right? You can just recognize, you know,
there's either a walk sign or a don't
walk sign.
And you understand what that means. You
know, you got to look across both sides
of the street before you cross, you
know, just don't think, you know, a lot
of traders come into trading looking for
some red light, green light system.
And then they start trading at red
light, green light, but they're not
looking to both sides of the street
before they cross. You know, they're not
taking it in context of what's going on
in the market, and that's why I think
it's important you have to understand
what's happening in the market because
even though, you know, I'm sure we've
everybody's experienced this, even
though you have the the green light to
go, as soon as you take a step out, some
car zips in front of you, right? That's
why you got to look both ways. That's
why you got to understand what's
happening in the market so that you can
um you know, protect yourself. You know,
everyone always talks about, you know,
you got to have good money management.
Yeah, of course you do. But you also
have have to have
market awareness. You know, take what's
happening in context and understand why
it's happening, and that's what Order
Flow is going to help you do.
So, before I jump in, you know, I just
want to go through a brief disclaimer.
This is not my lawyer, and he would
laugh when I say this is what I I
picture him looking like, but um but
anyway, this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only.
It should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading, and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. And again, you know, I want you
to understand trading is risky. Not
everybody that comes to the markets to
to make their fortune trading is going
to succeed. It's just like any other
business, you know, there is a high
failure rate. You know, everyone talks
about um you know, 90% of traders fail.
Well, you know,
I I remember
reading a an article about restaurants.
You know, 80% of people that open
restaurants fail. So, you know, don't
think that, you know, the odds are
stacked against you in in anything you
do. Yeah, you could be successful, but
you got to work at it. You know,
you got to ask, you know, what's the
point? Why are you trading?
You know, are are willing to stick with
it or or not? And you know, the reason I
got this picture of this guy up on the
scales because it's like with a diet.
Right? If this is why I always ask
people, you know, you got to figure out
is order flow for you. Is it something
you really want to do? You know, if it's
not, you know, if you don't want to put
in the time and effort, then you know,
don't don't need to watch my videos. Um
you know, if if you're just looking for
some holy grail,
there's no holy grail in in the markets.
You know, it takes work to be successful
whether it's in trading or anything in
life. And
like with a diet, right? If you're
overweight and you want to lose weight,
you know what you got to do. You got to
cut out the garbage food and you got to
start exercising.
And you know, there's not going to be
some special Hollywood diet that's going
to work for you in the long term. Yeah,
you may see some results in the short
term, you know, like my sister. Um you
know, she's a little bit on the heavy
side and we keep saying, you know, ever
since I was
you know, 12 years old, you know, she's
older than me. You know, she's
been battling weight problems. I mean,
she's not obese or anything, but you
know,
she's she's pushing it. And
you know, every time you talk to her,
she says, "Well, I lost 5 lbs. I've I I
lost 5 lbs." This has been going on for
the last 40 years.
And you know, I I figure out I I've
added it up. She must have lost about
3,000 lbs over the last 40 years. But
she still looks the same. You know, you
you know what you got to do to lose
weight and
get in shape. But most people don't want
to do it, right? They don't want to
eat the food that they don't want to
eat.
You know, they don't want to
do the work, do the exercise.
But more importantly though, they don't
want to stick with it, you know? And
that's important because it's like with
trading, right? You have to stick with
it.
If you want to be successful. And what I
mean stick with it is, you know, stick
with working to improve yourself as a
trader.
So,
first thing I'll talk about is the new
developments in order flow analysis. And
you know, there's there's a lot of new
developments in order flow analysis.
It's a bit of a ripe territory,
actually.
And that, you know, not a a lot of
people realize it. And it's interesting
to me, too, because, you know, order
flow has been around for, you know, well
over 100 years. You know, the
famous book on trading, you know, if you
read Market Wizards,
you know, the the interviews with, you
know, those
spectacular traders, one of the book
that, you know, majority of them
referred to is Reminiscences of a Stock
Operator. And it's quite interesting
because, you know,
the guy, Jesse Livermore, he was a tape
reader. And
that's a form of order flow analysis.
So, there's this quote in his book, you
know, "There's nothing new on Wall
Street or in stock speculation. What had
happened in the past will happen again
and again and again. This is because
human nature does not change. It is
and it is human emotion solidly built
into our human nature that always gets
in the way of human intelligence." And
what he's getting at is, you know, what
moves the market is human emotion.
All right? It's the collective buying
and selling by, you know, the the
different traders based on their
feelings of what the market should be
valued at and or where they think it
should be valued at in the future. Now,
like I said earlier, right? There's
there's new developments occurring in
the trading field, not just the order
flow field, um aspect of trading, but,
you know, in trading in general. And
often times, the general trading public
really have no idea of the analysis in
the trading that hedge funds do. Not
just hedge funds, but, um you know, the
big institutions, the banks, etc. And
you know, if you think that portfolio
managers
sit around drawing trend lines, flags,
fib ratios, etc.,
then, you know, you're you're not living
in reality because, you know, they don't
use those things. Um you know, there's
not much value in it for them. You know,
they they develop their own synthetic
contracts, right? They trade volatility
of one market against volatility of
another market. There's there's so many
different ways that they're approaching
the markets that you know, I could
literally do a presentation on it, but
it would it would cuz it would fit you
know, be hours. It would fill up this
you know, I I'd it just blow your mind
on some of the analysis that they're
doing, but that's not what this
presentation's about. Um you know, what
I'm trying to get at is
you know, people have moved on so much
from you know, the classic technical
analysis that it's almost not rendered
useless, but you know, it's one of those
things you know, they work sometimes,
they don't work sometimes. You know,
every known classical technical analysis
indicator
that you know, you've read in a book or
told you have to use is recognized
immediately by the microprocessor, you
know, the computer can can pick that up
much faster than you sitting there
looking at a chart than you know, trying
to make a decision and click a mouse.
You're not going to outperform a trading
algo trying to look for you know, that
that pattern in technical analysis.
You're just not. You know, the big
institutions, you know, they have the
fancy trading toys and access to
information the public doesn't always
have, but that's just the reality of
trading. You know, the big institutions,
you know, they've got guys out um
you know, in in the cornfields measuring
you know, how tall the corn is at
certain dates. You know, is is the corn
silking and and etc. that
they they they they think
excuse me.
I apologize. You know, they that they
think it's going to give them an edge
because it's going to give them better
understanding of where you know, that
corn market is going to go. You know,
how well production is going to be for
the year.
So, you got to ask yourself, you know,
do you want to compete against them or
or with them? You know, it's like
asking, you know, do you want to have
Michael Jordan on your team or do you
want to be playing against Michael
Jordan? Well, if you want to win, and
that's what trading is about, it's about
winning,
you're going to want him on your team.
Sure, you you want the satisfaction of
beating him, but the reality is maybe
you'll beat him once out of 100 times.
And, you know, I said you you beat
Michael Jordan once out of 100 times.
Yeah, that's a that's a great victory
for you, but
you know, that that's not something that
you're going to be able to make a living
on, you know, unless you sell a a book
on how to beat Michael Jordan, but you
know, your results are pretty lousy. You
want to be winning, right? You want
Michael Jordan on your
on your team, right? And that's where
where order flow comes in because with
order flow, you're not concerned about
the news or the chart patterns or other
technical analysis that's going on. What
order flow is going to allow you to do
is to see all that information,
fundamental and technical, is being
reacted to that by the market
participants, right? It's You're trading
basically human nature, and it's
revealed in the amount of trading
occurring at price levels in the market.
And, you know, that goes back to that
that quote I just showed you earlier
from Jesse Livermore.
You know, you're trading
you know, basically human nature, you
know, what humans are making decisions
on based on their own thoughts about the
market. So,
and that's reflected in what's being
traded in the market, right? And cuz,
you know, if somebody's made a trade,
they're committed to the market, you
know, whether they're long or short.
They have a view of what's going to
happen in the market. Now,
in order flow,
there's new developments in in order
flow
in the sense that, you know, there
there's new ways to analyze order flow,
and
it it's quite interesting,
I think, because
you know, there's a lot of software out
there. A lot of people a lot of software
companies are putting out
order you know, volume footprint charts
now and that's it. But they don't tell
you what what it means, right? It's just
a form of charting. That's all it is.
And you know, I've developed my own
software from orderflows.com, you know,
it's the orderflows trader.
And it's a volume footprint chart and we
show traders things in the order flow.
We highlight it out to them. So they're
not just looking at a chart and
wondering sitting there scratching their
head, what does this mean? What does
that mean? Or you know, are traders
trapped or you know, is the market is
someone sweeping through the order book?
You know, that's what the orderflows
trader is designed to do. It's
programmed to do that to
help you trade, you know, rather than
just give you the raw information out
there and you know, basically giving you
a flashlight and say, okay, find your
way home. You know, it's it's helping
giving you a map
to find your way home. So
like I said, there's there's many other
forms of
order flow analysis and I'm just going
to talk about a few here, right? The the
prominent point of controls, the market
sweeps and the trapped traders.
And
prominent point of control, every bar
has a point of control. Point of control
is is the price level in a bar that has
the most volume.
Well, it's traded on the bid side,
traded on the offer side. That's the
area
that's
the prominent the point of control
is I said the areas with the most volume
traded on the bid and the offer side,
okay? And prominent point of controls
are point of controls where
certain criteria are met in
um
I hate to say price action, but price
action, you know, recent price action.
You know, you you got to take what's
happening in the market in context. Um
you know, where it's occurring in the
bar. And also
volume, right? Because this deals with
volume, right? Point of control deals
with volume. So, there's going to be
areas sometimes where a point of control
means something. Not always. Point of
control, I said every bar has a point of
control, but not every point of control
means something. And you can see here,
right? There's a prominent point of
control here. This is a bearish
prominent point of control.
The market sold off.
A market sweep right here. It's
indicated with this arrow. Market sold
off. Trapped traders down here. Market
rallied. So, these are trapped traders
that were long. That's why there's a
green arrow. This is a sweep, bearish
sweep, which is a red arrow.
Uh multiple imbalances, which I'll talk
about a bit later. You know, there'll be
a box there, so it'll tell you that
there are more aggressive, in this case,
more aggressive buyers than sellers. In
this case, there's more aggressive
sellers
than aggressive buyers. And that's also
very important.
You know, a lot of people always talk
about trapped traders, but they don't
really define it. You know, they they
sit there and say, "Well, there's I
think there's trapped traders here." And
then key is
they they they think there's trapped
traders there. They can't define it. If
you're looking at a bar chart without
volume, you can't determine if traders
are trapped or not. You're just making a
guess. But if you can define it by using
volume,
then trading becomes easier.
And you know, these are just some of the
new developments that we've made in
order flows trader with order flow to
help you, the trader,
um you know, make better decisions. You
know, I'm not saying that you have to
take every part of point of control as a
short
or every sweep as a short or a long or a
trapped trader. But, you know, when it
when you put it in context with what's
happening in the market, I think it's
going to help you make better trading
decisions. And then that's what you want
to do. You want to make better trading
decisions.
Okay, here's another chart. This is
crude oil. This is yesterday.
You got a prominent point of control
here, multiple imbalances, the market
sold off, market starts rallying back
up. You got a sweep activity occurring
in here. Market rallied.
So, what is a sweep? Okay, some people
are not familiar with the vernacular
here. A sweep is
when a big order hits the market and
goes through several price levels. And
why is that important is because it's
often as a big trader that wants to get
into a position
now. Now, a sweep can occur when someone
gets out of a position. Honestly, you
know, when a trader gets into or out of
a position, you don't know unless you
are that trader. And
it will show up in the order flow
that type of
activity, you know, and and that's what
we define with the software.
Then you see here, so we rally up, and
then we can see some prominent point of
control. Got one here, one here. This is
a bearish one, this is a bullish one.
The blue color is bullish, the
magenta color is bearish. You also
multiple then you start seeing multiple
imbalances. So, multiple selling
imbalances in this bar, in this bar, in
this bar. Another prominent point of
control, a bearish one. So, you know,
what what's happening up here?
You hit a high.
You're seeing one, two, three, four
five things that's bearish. You got one
prominent point of control that's
bullish here. Okay, fair enough. But
overwhelmingly everything is bearish up
here right before the market starts
selling off.
So,
you know, you want to be able to analyze
as much as what's happening in the
market as it's happening. And order flow
allows you to do that. And like I said,
you know, once you understand the
concepts of order flow, it becomes a lot
easier. You know, most people look at a
chart like this and think, "Oh my gosh,
so many numbers.
I can't deal with that. I I just need a
clean chart." And honestly, I find this
very clean.
Um
it doesn't get very messy. You don't
need to draw lines and stuff. I mean,
you can,
but you know, you don't really need to.
You know, I've even
talked about the delta, which is the
difference between net aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in the bar, but
even coming down in here is very bullish
when you're looking at this delta.
So, you know, there's a lot of
information that's there, and
if you're just looking at a normal bar
chart, you're leaving out a lot of
information that's going to help you as
a trader.
And the next thing I talk about is
finding high percentage winning trades.
Now, you know, this is honestly a bit of
a
Uh, how to say it? You know, kind of a
sticky subject because
you know, when when people think about
trades, you know, everyone likes to
define everything. Oh, this trade had a
78.8%
winning percentage over the last 5
years. Okay, well, that doesn't
guarantee that going forward it's going
to be successful. You know, you could
look at the
seasonal analysis. You know, there's a
lot of seasonal analysis work out there
that's that's really good work. Um, you
know, Moore Research Center puts out,
you know, great stuff. I've been
following their stuff since the '90s
when I was on the trading floor. You
know, they put out the
the um,
the trades that
you know, have an 80% higher
you know, probability of occurring. But,
that doesn't mean it's going to keep,
you know, happen the next the next year.
Right? So,
you know, sometimes people get caught up
in percentage numbers that they
disregard other important facts, you
know, disregard what's happening in the
markets. And, you know,
you can't do that. You know, and that's
where a lot of people go wrong. You
know, they they think they're
getting
you know, something that is a very high
percentage winning trade, you know, a
97% chance of winning,
and it loses. So, what are you going to
do, you know?
It's
it I don't know how to describe it, but,
you know, don't get so caught up in
saying, you know, I need to know, you
know, what's your exact winning
percentage and, you know, for this type
of trade because, you know, you got to
realize there's different markets,
different time frames, and what type of
trader you are
versus what type of trader I am versus
what type of trader the guy down the
street is is completely different. We
got very different time frames. You
know, in our trading, you know, me, I
like to look at short-term.
Some people like to look at longer-term.
Some people even look at shorter-term
than me. You know, I I was surprised,
you know, me, I I tend to look at eight
range charts, four range charts. I had
some guy tell me he looks at three range
charts. I had some guy tell me he looks
at five second charts.
And I was just like,
I don't know how you could do it, but,
you know, that that's how they trade.
And so, you know, for me to say, you
know, this is how I I I don't like to
say this is how you have to trade. This
is what how I trade. And
you know, hopefully
you can get something out of it that can
help you in your trading. So,
every trader has access to the same
information. And
the Order Flows Trader software, you
don't need level two data. You just need
the the normal level one data that comes
out from the exchange cuz you're looking
at what's being traded in the market.
You're not looking at the depth of the
market. You need level two if you're
looking at depth of market.
And
what's the difference between level
um uh sorry, between, you know, a volume
footprint chart and a depth of market
chart or dome.
Um
you know, a dome just shows the orders
going in and out.
The volume, what's actually traded,
shows up in the volume footprint chart.
Which is more important to me, I think,
is the volume footprint chart. You know,
the dome just shows people's intentions.
What's actually traded shows people's
commitments.
And yeah, it's like being in a
relationship, okay? When you're
committed in a relationship, you you say
it, you know, you you give someone you
give the girl you're a ring, you know,
you get engaged, you know, that shows
your commitment to the relationship as
opposed to, you know, girls like
commitment and you know, for guys they
don't want to commit sometimes. And
that's what the order book is.
You know, it just shows what people are
thinking and doing. You know, then you
know, I've I've I've had friends who
basically the girlfriend said, look, you
I'm not going to waste any more time
with you. You better marry me or or
that's it. And you know, that's that's
the same with the order book. You know,
it's like the market is six bid at
seven.
But then you know, you see, well,
there's 1,500 offered at 12.
You know, oh, Bill Gates is up there
offering it out at at at 12. You know, I
I better sell now.
But then what happens as the market
starts trading up 7 8 9
10, that 1,500 at 12 becomes 800 and
300. By the time it starts trading 12,
there's maybe only 200 at because you
know, what, the guy's pulled his offer
and he's moved it up to 16.
You know, it's it's
when the market is 6 7, I would love to
sell 12s also. But you know, the the
odds of it spiking up and coming down
are are quite slim. But you know, what,
they have it there. Maybe they want to
lean on the market for whatever reason.
Okay. But you know, don't get so caught
up in the depth of the market that you
know, you're making trading decisions
based off of somebody's intention rather
than what's going on. You know, a
perfect example, my brother would always
say, hey, let's go on vacation. You
know, let's do this, let's do that. Then
when
time comes around to sit down and plan,
oh, I don't want to do it anymore. Well,
what the hell, why did you even bring it
up? And that's what to me is looking at
the order book.
So, rather than trying to guess the
future direction of the market as you're
trying to do with an order book, just
listen and watch what the market's
telling you the direction is going to
be.
So, we all want high percentage trades,
right? Because one, it helps your
account balance. That's important. And
two, it helps your mental balance, you
know? And the mental side of trading is
is something that not a lot of people
talk about, you know? As far as I'm
concerned, you know, there's there's
three basic building blocks of
being a successful trader. One is having
a good method of trading. You know, for
me that's order flow. Good money
management.
Risk risk management.
And third one is psychology.
Having the right mental balance, so to
speak, in in the market. So,
how do you go about finding
high-percentage winning trades with
order flows? You look at volume.
You know, how many people out there that
trade on a bar chart are looking at
volume? None of them are.
You know, they're just looking at price
action, but you can't take price action
alone
and make, I think, consistent
um good decisions without adding volume
to it. So,
you know, if there's one percentage with
high percentage It's one problem with
high-percentage winning trades is they
don't appear as often as you'd like.
And, you know, the reason for that is
because
in conditions in the market have to be
right, right? And how can you tell if
the market is ripe is is through volume?
And what do I mean by the market is
ripe? Well, you know, you go to the
the produce stand to buy some
um fruits, and you know, you
you cuz you want to eat, you know, you
want to eat uh trying to think, what's a
good one? You know, you want to eat a
mango, right? And you got to know how to
pick the the mango that's ripe that you
want to eat now, otherwise you're going
to eat the mango and it's going to be
sour. Or you got to wait 3 days to eat
it. You know, you want something that's
ripe, and same thing in trading.
You you got to wait sometimes for the
market to be ripe before you can sit
down and and start eating it.
Or or take the trades.
So, in simple terms,
you want to be buying when there's heavy
volume stopping a move down
or selling when there's heavy volume
stopping a move up. And you know, why is
that important? It's because
you can see you know, heavy volume is
indicative, you know, at lows is
indicative of support or heavy volume at
highs is indicative of resistance. And
you got to remember, if you're at a low
and heavy volume comes in, you know,
traders are thinking we're below value.
If we're at a high and heavy volume
selling volume comes in, traders think
we're above value and the market's going
to eventually move back towards value,
which is probably somewhere in the
middle.
Now,
the easiest way to do it, the easiest
way to see it when it's happening is
with the Orderflows Trader software
program, honestly. As it's going to
highlight on the chart when this is
occurring. You know, I'm a bit biased
because, you know, I developed this
software. I didn't develop the footprint
chart, but I developed the indicators on
there, which is again based on my own
experience trading. And
one of them is the prominent point of
controls. I think this is a very
important tool. And you know, I I I know
some people they built their whole
trading plan around prominent point of
controls. And this is in the crude oil
yesterday. And you can see
we had a prominent point of control down
here. That's this green
point of control, right? All normal
point of controls are these blue or
sorry, the
grayish areas in each bar. That's your
point of control. But this one based on
certain criteria is a prominent point of
control. Now, I'm not going to get into
it in this presentation what makes up a
prominent point of control, but what it
tells me is there's supportive buying
down here at this low.
And you can see how the market went up
from 6135 all the way up to, you know,
62 bucks
over the next 15 minutes. You know,
that's 65 cent move.
Close to 70 cent move in 15 minutes in
the crude oil.
And you know, that's what you want. You
know, when I talk about having high
percentage trades,
if there's a reason to be buying near a
low,
a legitimate reason,
in this case, there's
the volume reason,
then
you're going to be right more often than
wrong. Where do you want to be buying?
Do you want to be buying at a low? Do
you want to be buying at a high? There
There are times when, you know, you do
want to buy at a high. I used to be a
big breakout trader. I used to love buy
breakouts and sell breakdowns.
But
you know, I I I found it interesting
because
with breakouts,
sometimes the market would break out and
go five ticks, 10 ticks.
And sometimes it'll go 100 ticks. But
you know, it'd be like, yeah, I I I I
could have a high winning percentage,
but the amount of profits often times
are limited cuz eventually you're going
to hit that high.
You know, if you're buying at a low,
where's your potential? Your potential
is the entire day's range and
potentially keep going.
All right? So, if you had a reason to be
buying at the low, I think it's got much
more potential than buying at a high.
That's not to say that you can't buy
highs, of course you can. If there's
reasoning there.
But again, you know, where's your upside
potential? It can stop and then sell off
and and test the low.
Here is the euro currency yesterday.
Prominent point of control. Notice
there's no other prominent point of
controls in here. Like I said, every bar
has a point of control.
Doesn't mean it's important. You know,
some But some bars have them
where they mean something. And you can
see here how this market sold off
over the next, you know, hour and a half
from 11520
all the way down to, you know, the
11490s.
Okay, here's the minis.
Also yesterday on the uh
the 7th of November,
um you know, we start rallying back up,
go a little bit sideways, and
prominent point of controls tell me
there's some supportive buying coming in
here. Then the market rallied another,
you know, seven, eight points
before it hit a high. You know, this is
an an order flow thing here. This is a
divergence. This is a new high with
negative delta, which is a bearish sign.
So, had you been long, you have a sign
to get out in the order flow.
You know, people always say, "Well,
where's your target? Where do you get
out?" Well, if you see something in the
order flow
that goes contrary to your trade, that's
when you get out, right? If if you're
long and you're sitting here wondering,
"Should I get out now?" Then you see a
divergence, that's your clue to get out.
Then the market sold off.
Then sold off, started going sideways,
started making a little rally here.
But, there's a prominent bearish
prominent point of control coming in
right here, telling you there's some
resistance selling coming into the
market, and the market sold off again.
So,
you know, it's like I say, take things,
you know, understand when you understand
what's happening in the market, it
becomes easier to make trades. You know,
it's like looking at the crosswalk sign.
Should I cross or should I not cross?
You know, once you understand, you know,
you're looking both ways,
so to speak, looking both ways in the
street before you cross, that's the same
thing with understanding the market.
Now,
another high percentage winning trade
occurs when there's multiple imbalances
appearing in a bar. Now,
if you're not familiar with imbalances
in order flow, what they are is
they when occur when
there are more aggressive buyers versus
aggressive sellers, or a selling
imbalance occurs when there are more
aggressive sellers versus aggressive
buyers. And
the importance of that is
you got to realize that there's four
types of purchase four types of
trades that you could do. You could be
aggressive buyer, which means you buy
the offer,
buy at the market. You could be
aggressive seller, which means you sell
at the market. you you sell into the
bid. Or, you could be a passive buyer,
means you work a bid. Or, you could be a
passive offer, which means you work an
offer.
So, when you understand that, that's how
you measure if there's an imbalance in
the market. And it occurs when there's
more aggressive activity
on one side in the auction process.
Now, most people that are familiar with
the order flow are already familiar with
stacked imbalances, and those are easy
to see.
Most order flow software will highlight
them for you.
I don't want to say all software will
highlight it for you, because there
might be one or two softwares that
don't, but um
majority of them do. And what they do
what it is is this.
You have a stacked imbalance. You have
four in balance In this case, you have
four
selling imbalances stacked neatly one on
top of each other. 1 2 3 4.
And it draws out like a little zone
going across. And you could on my
software, you can put it out however
many levels you want. I choose to just
go um
four.
So, it's a total of five bars from where
it happens. But, I found four, you know,
I don't look at this to be support and
resistance for the whole day or anything
like that.
I'm just using as near term near term
support or resistance.
Now,
what the order flows trader software
does,
which no other software does, is it
highlights multiple imbalances.
Multiple imbalances are when there are
three or more imbalances in a bar. They
are not neatly stacked on top of each
other.
Now,
just because you have three or more
imbalances stacked on each other,
doesn't make it some super powerful
thing that the market must bend its will
to.
You know, you could have
multiple imbalances, more than one more
than um three or more imbalances in a
bar. If it's spread out in a bar, it's
just as important, you know, cuz
sometimes you do get the one price level
in between.
Um, you know, s- in between one or two
imbalances. And it doesn't mean that all
those imbalances don't matter.
No, you know, they still matter. And
most traders don't look for multiple
imbalances.
You know,
and it's I I I think they're missing out
on a lot of great trading opportunities.
Yeah, again, you know, only the Order
Flow Suite Trader software has this
feature.
And you can see here, right?
You got
down here, right off this low, you've
got the multiple imbalances right before
the market rallied.
Over here, you know, you have the
stacked imbalance in here. But, look at
the bar before it. You have multiple
imbalances. What the software does is it
puts a
sort of like this magenta pink box
around it.
Um,
for either buying, you know, if there's
buying imbalances or selling imbalances,
it's the same color. It's just a
highlight for you. It's an optical
thing.
Um,
and, you know, obviously in the bar with
the stacked imbalance, you have multiple
imbalances. But, now look, where would
you rather be short? Off the bar before
the bar with the stacked imbalances or
after the bar with the stacked
imbalances? Yeah, you're getting in one
bar earlier. You know, you're seeing
signs of aggressive selling coming in
before you even have the stacked
imbalance.
And then you're at your low at a swing
low or something, and you start rallying
back up. And then you see multiple
imbalances coming in here. You got
aggressive buyers coming in here right
before the market makes a big move up,
you know, from 78 all the way up to 88.
You know, that's a 10-point move that
you could have seen
using multiple imbalances. If you're not
looking at multiple imbalances, you miss
that move. If you're looking for
imbalances.
Okay. Again, you know, that's why I
talked about taking things in context.
You're at your high up here.
Okay.
What do you got As you start coming off,
multiple imbalances, right? Boom, right
before you sell off. Now, you know, I'll
just take it back here. Yeah, you got
you got a high here, you got
multiple imbalances. Now,
again, you know, so I talk about, you
know, taking things in context, you
know, forget the red light, green light
system.
If you're looking at the volume in here,
and you're trying to decide, you know,
is this you know, here's a stacked
imbalance, I got to get short. But
you're looking at it, it's seven against
zero, five against zero, nine against
zero.
Yeah, you know, maybe, you know, someone
had
you know, 50 lots to sell, okay? They
sold it.
And then the market went back to what it
was going to do anyway.
You know, over here it's stronger, 30
against one, 31 against four, 60 against
six, 33 against five.
That's a lot stronger than seven against
zero, five against zero, nine against
zero. That's why I say take it in
context with what's happening in the
markets.
A lot of traders don't do that.
And you know, this was this morning in
the crude oil before I
you know, but this was about 3:00 in the
morning before my before the
presentation on
um
you know, this is uh November 8th.
And we hit our high. Look at it, we at
our high, high of the day.
I have a divergence up here, so I got a
new high with negative delta.
Minus 72 is the delta, but I also got
aggressive selling coming in here. I got
multiple imbalances.
One against 14, or 14 against one, 42
against five, 17 against zero, 90
against one.
Aggressive sellers are taking over. Say,
yeah, I'm not convinced there. Okay,
fine.
Couple bars later, you got another bar
with multiple imbalances, and right
before this market sells off.
Okay? So, you know, when you start
taking what's happening and putting it
in context
of the market, you know, what's
happening in the order flow
and understanding it in context of the
market it really is going to give you
better trading decisions, higher winning
percentage trades.
So, context context context.
You know, when you take what's happening
in the market
and what the market is trading at, where
it's trading at, that's what taking
things in context are, right? If the
market is You have to ask yourself, is
the market trading at or near highs? If
it is, do you want to be buying or
selling? You know, there's like I said,
there's times where we're at highs that
you'd want to be buying or there's times
where you're at highs you want to be
selling. Is the market trading at or
near the lows? Do you want to be buying
there or do you want to be selling
there?
And you know, those are questions that
you have to constantly ask, you know,
are we trading in the middle of a range?
You could have the best indicator in the
world, you know, the super
you know, the super duper indicator A1
plus thing that
you know, always works, but if you're in
the middle of a range, it's probably not
going to be very effective. It may work,
may work just a little bit, but it's not
going to be very effective. And that's
why I say, you got take things in
context of the market, take trades in
context of the market.
Don't fall into this thing like, "Oh, I
have to take this trade because you
know, the indicator says buy here." You
know, if the signs aren't there, then
don't take the trade. Now, the last
thing I want to talk about is
you know, it's a bit on on the on the
psychological side and it's stop waiting
and start trading.
You know, where are you now in your
trading? Where do you want to be? Are
you sitting on the bench or are you in
the game?
Now, if you're sitting on the bench,
again, you know, there's there's nothing
wrong with trading, you know, practicing
your trading. You all have to We all do
that. But, at some point
you got to get in the game. You got to
start trading. You got to put down the
pencil and paper and start trading. And
you know, I
grew up in Illinois and there's always
the the lottery
commercials growing up.
You got to be in it to win it, right? If
you're not in it, if you're not playing
it, you can't win. And it's the same
thing as trading, you know, you can sit
here and
go on sim and practice and all that and
trading in real life, you know, with
real money is completely different than
trading in sim. You know, lots of times
people trade in sim and they're like,
"Ah, you know, I'll just
not going to run my stop. I'll let it go
a little wider."
But, you know, when you're trading with
real money, it's completely different.
So, you have to start
I hate to say it, but you know, you got
to start trading with real money at some
point if you want to be
a successful trader. You know, you can't
just sit there and back test for years
and years and years. I mean, there's
other things that you're
probably better off spending that time
with. You know, you can find out really
quick if trading is for you
if you open up a small account. You can
open accounts with a couple thousand
bucks and start trading. If you can't
handle the risk, forget it. Go on
find something else, you know, cuz like
I said, you know, trading can be very
good, very rewarding, but it can also be
very frustrating. The last thing you
want to do is, you know, start trading
not be very successful at it and then
start taking it out on those around you
that love you. You know, and that's what
sometimes people do. So, you got to even
find out if trading is for you. But
again, you know, stop waiting and start
trading. And
taking it on a smaller scale,
you know, everybody likes to wait for
the perfect trade setup, right? Like,
here you open up a book on
double tops and this is what it looks
like, okay? You got top one, top two.
This is your support down here, this
neckline. When you break that area, you
get short. You know, they all like to
sit here and wait and wait for this.
Okay, well, I know I got to wait for
that. I can't take any trades.
Traders trade. They don't sit around
waiting for the ideal setup that often
just doesn't come.
You know, you can sit here, well, I'm
waiting for this to happen and it
doesn't happen, you know. Gartley
patterns, you know, you see a lot of
people talking about Gartley patterns.
Yeah, when they work, they look
beautiful, honestly, but how often do
they appear? Not very often.
And, you know, looking at this, you
know, this is over
um about 3 days.
You know, from X to A to B to C to D.
Then, okay, maybe you got a trade.
But, often times, you don't even get to
the D. You don't even get to the C and
you just wasted 3 days. But, look at all
this activity between X to A,
A to B. There's so many great trading
opportunities, you know, you could have
been short here at B just on basic well,
you know, support and resistance, you
know, if you're just looking to the left
a little bit. I don't even know I've
even looked at the order flow for this,
but there's so much great trading
opportunities here that trade, you know,
if you're sitting around waiting for,
you know, the the bat pattern to appear,
then you're just
wasting your time, you know, especially
if you're on a daily chart or
heaven forbid a monthly chart, you know,
on a daily chart, you could be sitting
here waiting.
Yeah, you get into the trade and you got
to wait freaking 8 months to get out of
it, you know.
Hopefully, it's going in your favor that
whole 8 months. If you're underwater,
it's going to be very tense time.
So, you know, traders trade and once you
understand the market, especially with
order flow,
if you're trading during the day, if
you're an intraday trader, the order
flow is
is designed for trading intraday. It's
not designed for taking positions and
riding them out for a couple days.
You know, when you understand what's
happening in the order flow, then
trading just becomes, yeah, you could
it becomes a lot easier, you know.
Like here,
you know, I talked about the multiple
imbalances, right? You have a reason to
be getting short here. You even got
multiple imbalances over here. I didn't
put a circle around it, but you have
them appearing here, right? Then you got
a prominent point of control here. Even
here, you got multiple imbalances,
you know? So, I mean, look at this.
Suppose you
Let me just copy this here, right? If
you
you know, if you're just looking at the
multiple imbalances, right?
Look at that.
And then even up here is another one.
You know, multiple imbalance, okay? I I
should be trading it from the short
side. Multiple imbalance, I should be
trading it from the short side. This is
an order flow to um
bullish
ratio down here, which I'm not even
talking about the ratios, you know? This
was on the earlier version of Order
Flows Trader. There's bullish ratios,
there's bearish ratios. And you can see
how the market turns at each often times
at each uh
at each level. But, multiple imbalance,
multiple imbalance where the market
rallied, multiple imbalances the market
starts selling off.
You know, once you understand what's
happening
with order flow,
you're going to be taking more trades,
you know? This is just from 6:45 in the
morning until 8:44. And you got at least
1 2 3 4 5 opportunities based on just
one part two parts of order flow
prominent point of control. If it's just
looking at multiple imbalances, you got
four opportunities. If you're looking at
a Gartley pattern, you got them 3 days
without even taking a trade.
You know, I mean, people trade to make
money.
You know, and and I said, "How you going
to make money if if you're not trading?"
You know, you don't get paid to sit
around at a bank as a trader and not
take trades. You got to you got to start
trading, period.
So,
here's another chart. You know, this is
E-minis and
you know, you got a prominent point of
control a short on a short side here.
Now, then even up here another prominent
point of control short signal up here
bearish prominent point of control.
Now, if you understand point of
controls, I'm not going to get into it,
but there's plenty of opportunities to
be getting long here, long in here,
long in here, long in here. You know, as
the market's moving up, you know, so a
lot of traders I think leave a lot of
money on the table, right? If they're
long
and you're seeing more signs that you're
in a good trade, you could add to the
longs. I'm not saying you A lot of
people like to add to their losers
thinking they're going to dollar cost
average, but where a lot of hedge funds
make money is they add to winning
positions.
And there's no reason why you as a
trader
a retail trader can't do that yourself.
But, you know, these longs are based on
the point of controls. You know, I
recently put out a point of control
course where I talk about different
patterns and point of controls and I
break them down on what you should be
looking for. This is actually multiple
imbalances in here all right off this
low, but if you're following the point
of controls,
you know that you're on the right side
of the market. You getting long, adding
to the position as this market keeps
rallying. You know, here's a short
Here's it is on the short side. This is
euro currency this time.
Yeah, a couple long signals here. Okay,
and nothing spectacular. Market goes up,
market goes up. This is bearish signal
here with the point of control. Then you
start seeing signs, you know, in the
point of controls, in the multiple
imbalances, point of controls coming in.
You know, as the market starts selling
off. So, you sort of get into a rhythm
with what's happening in the market so
you can make better
trading decisions and
you know, because you understand what's
happening in the market. You know, it's
It's one of those things like driving,
you know? Trading should be
like driving for you. And
what does that mean is, you know, when
you first started out driving, you know,
you took a course, probably, you know,
you read a few books, you know, I know
in Illinois you got the rules of the
road.
But once you start driving and
understanding
you could sort of
you know, you're still alive, so you
know how to drive. You've internalized
the instructions and you can understand
the flow of traffic, right? You know if
there's
a car
acting erratically in the market in in
the road, you know, you know how to
react. If you come into a stop sign or,
you know, a roundabout, you know how to
react. And the same thing should be it
should be like that in your trading,
right? You should know how to react
because you know how to read what's
happening in the market.
Now,
by now you should see how powerful the
order flow analysis is, you know, don't
overcomplicate trading. You know, people
love to overcomplicate things, you know,
whether it's in trading or whether it's
in relationships, you know, people
always like to screw things up.
And don't do that.
You know, keep it simple.
Simplicity is best. Less is more.
And if you found this helpful,
you're going to really like my Order
Flows Trader 2.0 package. Now, Order
Flows Trader it runs on NinjaTrader 8.
There is a version available for Sierra
Charts through Emoji Trading.
You just go to Emoji Trading
and you can get a trial there if you're
on Sierra Charts or if your broker
offers you Sierra Charts, you get it
there. But
I prefer currently I I'm still on
NinjaTrader 8 and
that's how this is what this software
was developed for. I find NinjaTrader a
little bit easier to use than Sierra
Charts, but that's a personal thing,
okay? Just because I've been using
Sierra Charts for a lot longer or I've
been using NinjaTrader a lot longer than
Sierra Charts.
And it'll work on the free version of
NinjaTrader, so in the this version of
Order Flows Trader 2.0 is designed for
NinjaTrader 8, not 7. If you're on 7,
get 8. You know, eventually Ninja
Trader, even though they won't say it,
they're going to cut out Ninja Trader 7.
They're not going to say it officially,
but I mean, come on, you know,
I know people that still like to use I
have a computer with Windows 7, but I
can't get support for it. Um so,
go on to the the new version of Ninja
Trader 8. I think they just released
version 16 recently.
Um but it'll work on version 15. If
you're on an earlier version, it's free
to upgrade. You just go to the Ninja
Trader website and enter your license
key.
Now, what you get with your order flow
traders, you get the volume footprint
chart and seven pre-programmed order
flow indicators. I've talked about just
I've talked about prior point of
controls. I've talked about multiple
imbalances, trapped traders, um sweeps,
but there's also um
a few other things. You have single
prints,
divergence,
and one other thing I can't remember
right now off the top of my head, but
you also going to get my chart template.
And that's important because, you know,
you want your charts, ideally, to look
like my charts, right? You want to
Yeah, you watch my videos, you see what
I talk about, and if you got to sit here
and spend more than 5 minutes trying to
figure out your chart, cuz honestly,
to set up a chart to look like this by,
you know, if you're not familiar with
Ninja Trader, it's probably going to
take you
days cuz you're going to be so
frustrated, you're going to want to
throw your computer out the window and
pound a bunch of vodka at the same time.
But you're going to get my template, so
all you got to do is you just copy
and drop it into um your Ninja Trader
template folder so that you can open it
your charts up to look like mine. And
most importantly, you're going to get
access to I I do a live group training
for users of my software. And it happens
Monday nights 7:00 p.m.
Usually last about an hour.
Um where I talk about, you know, things
in the order flow that I saw over the
last few days or or pre- well, I see the
previous week or that day. And you know,
it's just a great place to pick up
things that
you know, you probably won't get
elsewhere. And you know, I don't
necessarily publish as many videos
nowadays as I'd like to. It's just a
time constraint, but I make time to do
this group training. Now, it's not every
week. You know, if if I don't do it one
week, I'll usually send out an email the
day of saying I'm not going to do it
because you know, I said I got kids and
sometimes things come up that I I just
can't do it. You know, sometimes the
school says, "Oh, we got this meeting
tonight. Need you there." So, I got no
choice. I got to go. Um but in general,
you know, it's it's weekly.
And it it's a great resource.
You know, that's a live group training.
And normally, I sell the software for
$899 on my website, okay? Just for this
software.
And
I realize that having order flow
software is one thing. Next thing is you
got to know how to use it, right? I
mean, what's the point of having a
software if you don't know how to use
it? And that's a problem cuz a lot of
people don't know how to use their order
flow software. And I know a lot of
people have spent a lot of money for
other softwares
much, you know, three, four, five times
the price of my software and don't know
how to read order flow.
And then, you know, they they get my
software for a lot lesser and they
think, "Geez, I just wasted $4,000 on
on some other software and I don't know
what I'm doing. But your software really
makes it a lot easier." The order flow
is trader just, you know, it stands head
and shoulders, I think, above a lot of
the other software cuz this is what I've
done is I've taken my knowledge and I've
put it into the footprint charts, like
having me sit next to you
while you're trading. Saying to you,
"Hey, you know, this point of point of
control is is a very bullish point of
control." Or, you know, I think there's
trapped traders here. So, I don't just
give you software and send you on your
way. I give you a lot of extra education
on how to trade with order flow. I have
a course on order flow trading. It's
called the order flow trading course.
It's 20 lessons, 15 hours of video.
Yeah, you can bang it out in in about a
weekend or you could watch one every day
for you know, not everyone is not every
course is
an hour or anything like that. I think
you know, the last two sections are are
is long takes up the most of it, but
it really covers a lot of but basically
covers you know, the basics of order
flow. I wanted to create something short
that would last about you know, 6 hours,
but then when I started doing it
I realized there was a lot of different
things with order flow you need to know
and I tried not to leave
um anything out when I made this course,
you know, so it give you a great basis
for um understanding order flow. Now
again, you know, I really want you to be
successful in trading and being good at
order flow. So I'm going to give you
access to
my order flows inner circle video
series, which I normally sell for $500.
And what it is there's 56 videos on
advanced order flow tricks, tips and
analysis. And
this is good because it really is going
to help you take your order flow to a
whole another level. You know, the
previous course, which I sell for 297
talks about you know, the volume
footprint chart, what all this
information means on the chart, you
know, how to read absorption and price
rejection and things like that, but the
inner circle
you know, takes it a step further.
If this
trading course is like you know, your
college
your first level English
this is
you know, um
senior year
you know, level 400 uh English or
something like that is the way I
describe it. So you add that up, you
know, 899 for the software, 297 for the
training, 497 for the inner circle video
series.
That comes out to just about $1,700, but
you're not going to pay $1,700.
I don't want you to pay so much
for that.
You know, to be honest, I've
have some users that have told me, Mike,
you're selling your stuff too cheap. Um
you should
what you're offering should be priced a
lot higher, you know,
in the thousands. But again, you know, I
I don't want to do that cuz you know, if
I know for a lot of people new to
trading, you know, they want to learn to
trade,
you know, eventually get to that point
where
you know, they they want
a steady stream of income. And that's
why I try to provide education at a
reasonable cost for people. So,
you know, because of Investor
Inspiration having me back so often,
I've got a special deal. I'm going to
also throw in the Trader Kickstart
program, which normally I sell for $297.
I'm going to throw it in for free. And
what this covers is covers the um
psychological side of trading, you know,
why traders succeed, why traders fail,
how to deal with stress. You know, I
talk about journaling. I talk about um
a lot of things. There's 12 different
lessons in here. And you know, it's a
great
addition to, you know,
order flows because
like I said, you know, the the three
core aspects of trading come
methodology, money management, risk
management, and psychology. And this
covers the psychology part of it, you
know, which a lot of people neglect. And
that's I think why a lot of people fail
in their trading. So, you know, you add
all that up, that comes out to almost
$2,000, $1999. It's $899 for the
software, $297
for the training,
$497 for the Inner Circle videos, $297
for Trader Kickstart.
But you're just going to pay a one-time
payment of $799.
Right? There's no other monthly payments
or
you know, recurring charges. Of course,
you know, obviously you do have to pay
your data fees and NinjaTrader fees.
The software will run on the free
version of NinjaTrader.
So, you know, you what you could do, you
know, if you're cheapskate like uh me, I
I I don't like to pay full price for
stuff. Um you can run a a free version
of NinjaTrader.
Um get data from say Kinetic or open up
a NinjaTrader account and
you get the data. If you have
NinjaTrader account, you can get their
data feed from NinjaTrader, which is
from CQG, and run it through
NinjaTrader. Um you have to pay $5 for
CME, five for CBOT, five for NYMEX.
So, instead of getting like a data feed
where you're paying, you know, $91 a
month for CME,
another 91 for um
CBOT, 91 for NYMEX, you have a
NinjaTrader account, you know, you're
you got to pay data fees, so that's a
way to reduce your data fees. And you
can still trade with the free version,
you just got to pay slightly higher
commission. Or if you're using if you
have another broker's platform, you can
just enter your orders through that.
So, again, you just go to
orderflows.com/oft2.
www.orderflows.com/oft2.html.
Now, you know, there's a lot of comments
online, you know, some people like me,
some people hate me.
Um you know, this is what the nicer
comments, you know, Mike, your order
flows trader software is remarkably
helpful.
Cuz I can clearly see now what's
happening in the market. Like for
example, who's in control of the market
on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well.
Okay, so
again, you know, not everybody is cut
out for trading and
you know, oftentimes, you know, people
aren't happy
that they can't learn how to trade and
they they just become miserable. Um you
know, hopefully
I can reach out to you and and hopefully
you can become successful in the
markets. So,
what you do is you go to
orderflows.com/oft2.html.
This is what the page looks like. Scroll
down, there's a couple videos on there
and and a of examples. You scroll down
the page, you get down here,
you click uh buy now. You know, I want
this. You know, you want to change your
life. You want to become a better
trader. Takes you to PayPal. PayPal
processes your payment. I don't process
it. I don't get your credit card
information. I don't want your credit
card information. It's handled through
PayPal.
And that's it. You know, then shortly
I'll send you after once the payment is
processed, I'll send you all the
details. I'll show you send you the
links for the software and
logins for the courses.
And you know, the additional
guides that I've written on trading as
well. So, you know, why should you join
Order Flows? Because you see the power
of Order Flow trading and how it can
improve your trading. You know, you want
to understand what's happening in the
markets. You're excited to find low risk
trading opportunities.
And you want a life of freedom and
fulfillment. You know, I mean, that's
why a lot of people come in into trading
is because they want freedom in their
life. They want to get away from being
chained down to, you know, a job.
You know, they want to be able to travel
the world, see things,
give their wife and family a better
life. And that can be done through
trading. You know, I'm I'm a perfect
example. You know, when I got into
trading, I had no experience in the
markets. You know, I had a desire,
but desire alone isn't going to help you
be successful. You know, you got to take
the steps necessary to become successful
in anything. So, go to orderflows.com
/oft2.html.
And I hope to see you on the inside. You
know, and again, you know, if there's
one parting comment I can make, it's
just stop flushing your money down the
toilet buying
the latest greatest holy grail in
trading and then returning it two weeks
later saying it doesn't work. You learn
how to trade. Learn how to understand
what's happening in the markets. It's
going to help you
immensely. You know, one thing is
with knowledge. You know, once you learn
something, people can't go into your
head and take it away. And you know,
whether you're
Um excuse me.
No matter what happens in your life,
if you learn a skill that's going to
help you in the future, you know,
if
you you know how to do carpentry, if you
know how to do plumbing, there's always
going to be a demand for you. If you
know how to trade rather than relying on
an indicator to make trading decisions,
you're going to be a better trader. So,
you know, take action. Do something with
your life. Go to
orderflows.com/opt2.html.
And again, you know, I hope to see you
on the inside and thanks for your time
and bye-bye.